There's a seventh primitive type
that's been added to JavaScript.
What are the existing six
primitive types in JavaScript?
We got number, string, object,
Boolean, null, and undefined.
Now we have a seventh one, which
is a symbol. Symbols are pretty
simple, but they take a little
bit to wrap your head around,
because I don't think that a lot
of people were actually asking
for these things in the language.
But I can see where it would be
useful. Symbols are unique
identifiers. They pretty much
help us avoid having naming
collisions. Anytime that you
want to create a property in a
unique way, that's when you
should reach for a symbol.
Let's take a look at a symbol
right here. I say const Wes =
symbol, and then you pass it.
This is not a value. This is
what is called a descriptor. The
symbol itself is just a unique
identifier. If you were to
visualize what a symbol would be,
maybe you could visualize it as
something like this, "absolute
unique symbol," so I can make
sure that it never overrides any
other piece of code in there.
This right here, that's just a
descriptor. Because otherwise, I
would have no idea what that
actual thing is, so I've
described it as Wes here. If we
go into our console and type in
Wes, the variable, you'll see
that it is then a actual symbol.
What's cool about this is if I
create a second symbol, like
person, and I create a symbol
here with Wes again, are those
two things going to be the same
because I described them as the
same thing? Let's see. Wes,
person, Wes = person? No. What
about like ==. No, not allowed
either. That's one thing that
you need to know about symbols,
is they are absolutely unique,
and you'll never have a naming
collision with them. That could
be useful if you were creating
an object of your class, so I
say const class =...Don't make
it class. That's a reserved word.
Const classroom =, and you
wanted to name everybody off.
Maybe you have Mark. You say
Mark, his grade is a 50,
and his gender is a male. Then
you have another, Olivia, grade
is a 80, gender is
female. Then you have another
Olivia, because these days every
person born is named Olivia.
You've got a naming collision
there. You could put some sort
of guarantee unique identifier
and hope that they never overlap,
but that could run into issues,
especially when you have a lot
of data. Think about if you were
doing some 3D work or working
with Canvas, where you have
millions and millions of pieces
of data that you're working with
at a single time. Rather than
using the person's name or some
sort of unique identifier, we
can use a symbol to name them.
Here, we'll say symbol of Mark
is this one. Then we'll do the
same for both of the Olivias...
The square bracket
symbol Olivia. Even though these
are the exact same things, now
they're not going to be
overwritten if we refresh. Now,
if you look at classroom, you'll
see that we've got symbol,
symbol, symbol, and you would be
able to see them. Another thing
we need to know about symbols is
that they're not enumerable,
which means that we cannot loop
over them. Watch, if I were to
do use form person in
classroom...Remember, I'm not
using "person of" because you
cannot use "of" within object in
order to console log the person,
I get nothing. Why? Because
symbols aren't enumerable. For
that reason, sometimes people
use them to store private data,
because you're never going to be
looping over any of your symbols.
Maybe if you had information
about someone that you didn't
want to be looping over, you
could store that data in an
actual symbol. If you do want
to get access to all of your
symbols, because obviously
there's some information that
you would want to get here, you
can use the object method, get
own property symbols. I'll say,
object.getOwnPropertySymbols,
and then you pass it, the object
you want to grab all of the
symbols off of, so pass it
classroom here. I'll just say
const syms =, and then we'll
console log the syms. Let's see
what we got here. What that
gives is an array of just the
symbols themselves. Remember
that the symbols aren't the
actual object here. The symbols
are just the property keys that
are inside of classroom. How do
I actually get the data? There's
no data in here at all, and look,
these two things are exactly the
same. But if I were to then take
all of my syms, symbols, let's
say const data =, I can map over
each of those symbols, and take
each symbol and return classroom
square bracket sym. Why?
Because the symbol is the
equivalent of something like
that, and it's going to be able
to pull back Mark, Olivia, and
Olivia, even though these two
things are exactly the same. By
using that symbol as the
property key, I'm now going to
be able to access my data. Let's
see it console log the data here.
There, that's how you actually
get it. A little bit of a
workaround, but if you do need
to ever store some private data,
or you want to make sure that
your keys in your object are
absolutely unique, that's when
you should reach for a symbol.